I'd like to talk for just a minute about
how the basic physics of climate change
works so that if you ever run into your
you know crazy uncle fred who doesn't
believe in this you can start quizzing
them about their knowledge of basic
chemistry and i can guarantee you this
is a way to at least end the discussion
so i got my friend leland who is a
wonderful cartoonist to draw these
pictures so here you have the sun right
it's bathing the Earth with every
imaginable kind of light ultraviolet
microwaves you name it about a third of
that bounces off either the clouds or
dust in the air or the surface there's a
little bit absorbed notably the
ultraviolet is absorbed by the ozone
layer the remaining two-thirds lands on
the ground or water or vegetation you
guys are clear with this right okay
great
now all this different kind of light
comes here it heats up the ground it
heats up the vegetation it heats up the
water they emit infrared light this one
type of light and so different kinds of
light come in infrared light goes out
we're halfway done so here's a weird
fact that was discovered in the 1870s
nitrogen and oxygen make up about 99% of
the atmosphere they can't absorb
infrared light so the atmosphere is
entirely made out of nitrogen oxygen all
this infrared light would pass right
through it and we would be in a snowball
we'd be frozen okay but water vapor
which is just about 1% of like can take
it in and that's a good thing because
the water vapor absorbs most of the
infrared light and then passes it to the
nitrogen oxygen and we have our present
warm earth that's how the atmosphere
works now water vapor doesn't absorb all
the infrared it lets just a few
frequencies just a few wavelengths
through and this is a good thing because
just enough energy escapes to prevent
the earth from getting unbearably hot
and here you see here is Leland's water
molecule giving the side-eye
to this particular frequency saying no
I'm not going to absorb you now so the
whole system is works really great you
know the water vapor absorbs most most
of it but enough gets through that it
keeps it at this sort of Goldilocks
temperature but here's the bad guy
carbon dioxide it comes in
and remember this is the water vapor
giving it the side-eye it absorbs by
sheer bad luck for us just those
frequencies that water vapor would
otherwise let through so now when you
have a lot of carbon dioxide almost all
of it
almost all the infrared is being
absorbed in the atmosphere and it gets
hotter that's all there is to it there's
lots of sort of secondary complications
but there is nothing more to it than
that
and it just infuriates scientists when
people say oh it's a hoax because this
is basic chemistry if this is wrong
a whole lot of chemistry is wrong a
whole lot of physics is wrong your high
school fit textbook you can just you
know chew it up and throw it away this
is really really basic stuff now they of
course because there are terrible
communicators they showed diagrams like
this this is the same thing as Leland's
nice pictures well you can see here is
here is the wavelengths there is the
absorption it goes through here and here
is the carbon dioxide sitting sitting
there this is a drawn diagram from 1992
which is redrawn from a 1920
spectroscopy textbook I mean this is not
new but the big point is again if this
is wrong a lot of basic chemistry is
wrong too now I'm going to give you one
more attempt to get this because I'd
really think it's we should actually
understand what's gonna kill us if it's
gonna kill us imagine that the
atmosphere is like a bathtub and the
water pouring in is the infrared light
you're sitting there all cozy there's
these little holes in the bathtub
they'll let the water come out and just
about balance between the water coming
out and the water coming in now take
some chewing gum plug up those little
holes one or just one or two of them
that's all you need to plug up and very
slowly the water will begin to rise and
things to go to hell
that's climate change that's all it is
and so again this is what I scientists
go crazy it isn't like you know they
always say there's a 97% consensus
there's a hundred percent consensus on
basic chemistry and physics the only
question is exactly how fast that water
is going to rise